und das sieht einfach so aus und ich
denke mir da liegen doch jetzt so fünf
jahre zwischen oder anders gesagt und
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut ich rege mich irgendwie gerade ein
bisschen auf eigentlich wollte ich
morgen nach berlin fliegen und genau
jetzt steht hier dass der flug
gestrichen wurde
naja dann kann ich zum friseur gehen
herzlich willkommen zum neuen video ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schon
gelesen es geht heute mal wieder um
ungeschminkt world ist geschminkt der
erste teil ist eigentlich ziemlich gut
bei euch angekommen und da habe ich mir
gedacht aufgrund der großen resonanz
also auf ins tal kommen wir sehr viele
von euch ein foto zugeschickt einmal
geschminkt einmal ungeschminkt
ungeschminkt ungeschminkt und ich habe
einfach mal wieder so zehn stück heraus
gesucht und wir schauen uns die mal an
ganz wichtig was ich zuvor noch
loswerden möchte an die spezialisten
unter euch jetzt sagen würde für server
film video ich finde so make up gehört
halt irgendwie mittlerweile zur
gesellschaft dazu und die idee hinter
diesen videos soll nicht sein irgendwie
leute darauf aufmerksam zu machen hey du
solltest dich vielleicht doch besser
schmecken bevor es losgeht ganz wichtig
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal wir
sind gerade bei 33,4 prozent von allen
leuten die das video schauen habe ich
abonniert das muss eigentlich wieder ein
bisschen weiter nach oben
deswegen habe jetzt zwei sekunden zeit
12 und los es gibt einfach so viele
unterschiedliche menschen die einen
sehen mit schminke besser aus die
anderen sehen ohne schminke besser aus
die anderen sehen mit schminke viel
älter aus die anderen springen sich
überhaupt nicht und darauf gehen wir
einfach so ein bisschen ein einfach weil
ich es auch krass findet zu sehen die
leute halt dann plötzlich ganz anders
aussehen aber ihr werdet es auch merken
dass ich hier keinen irgendwie
bloßstellen will oder so viele haben ja
auch text dazu geschrieben wir können
zum beispiel mit diesem jahr anfangen
und zwar hat die lahme geschrieben haye
hat gerade ein video geschaut und
irgendwie waren alle aus seinem vorher
nachher videowall natürlich geschminkt
ich sehe mit schminke wie ein anderer
mensch aus
[Musik]
hahahaha also hier haben wir die lara
einmal ohne schminke ein bisschen
überbelichtet aber man muss sagen sie
sieht da wirklich echt jung aus und dann
hat sie mir ein foto geschickt wie sie
mit schminke aussieht und das sieht
einfach so aus und ich denke mir da
liegen doch jetzt so fünf jahre zwischen
oder ich meine schaut euch das so
einfach mal an einmal dieses bild moment
mal da ist noch eine zweite person auf
dem bild ist wahrscheinlich die freunde
oder die mutter ich will jetzt auch die
zweite sagen die im spiegel das foto
macht oder die kann man halt im spiegel
sehen keine ahnung ist ja auch egal auf
jeden fall gebt euch dieses bild die
lager sie finde ich meiner meinung mir
das jetzt nicht böse oder sechste siebte
klasse und dann einfach dieses und was
sie schon deutlich eine aus gutes
abhänge heim ist mir dass es solche
fälle gibt aber ich finds halt krass so
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten foto
und zwar haben wir hier die der name
steht leider nicht dabei das wäre jetzt
mal ein gutes beispiel wo man nicht
wirklich sagen kann
ich sehe jetzt geschminkt oder nicht
schaut euch dieses bild machen ich würde
sagen das ist ungeschminkt und wenn man
dann dieses bild anschaut würde ich auch
sagen das ist ungeschminkt jetzt sagen
wahrscheinlich die mädchen unter euch
auch alex wie kommen wir dass du nicht
sehen dass erstes natürlich geschminkt
ich habe absolut keine ahnung gehabt
wahrscheinlich da an die einspringen
sich mehr die anderen weniger
ich habe auch irgendwie darauf gewartet
dass mir die jungen bild schickt wo er
sich schminkt weil das gibt's ja auch
kann aber irgendwie kainz also hier sind
nur mädels drin bis zur nächsten person
ich glaube sie weiß schon etwas älter
das ist lisa schöne grüße an dieser
stelle haben wir sie einmal ungeschminkt
glaub ich ja wenn nicht sieht aber auch
schon gut aus und jetzt haben wir sie
ihm geschenkt ja so ein bisschen die
augenlider gold gemacht und lippenstift
und könnte jetzt zum beispiel gar nicht
sagen was ich besser finde ich will
eigentlich beides gut
deswegen sagen wir einfach mal wir
machen weiter hier könnt ihr gerne in
die kommentare schreiben was ihr besser
findet oder nach dem video kommentiert
ihr welchem fall ihr am krassesten
findet das für mich auf jeden fall mal
interessieren also lisa noch mal schöne
grüße und wir machen weiter mit der
nächsten person das wird auf jeden fall
jetzt auch christi haben wir das
erste foto ungeschminkt so wird mir das
zumindest gestellt die muss ich jetzt
einmal auch wieder sagen nicht übel ich
weiß ich sehe auch jünger aus als ich
bin ständig manchmal zumindest das
könnte auch wirklich noch grundschule
sein
einigen wir uns auf fünfte klasse sieht
halt so voll unschuldig aus man könnte
sich jetzt die situation vorstellen sie
ist somit einer freundin draußen auf
einer spielwiese und die schwingen zu
mit pferden klar die meisten medien
heutzutage machen sowas schon gar nicht
mehr ich meine es gibt ja schon snapshot
filter aber so würde ich das jetzt
einfach mal locker einordnen und jetzt
haltet euch fest jetzt kommt nämlich das
andere bild geschminkt und das finde ich
wirklich extrem heftig ich meine hier
sieht es jetzt auch nicht aus wie 20
aber schon so 16 würde ich mal sagen und
zwischen der fünften klasse ich weiß
nicht wer da ist man als zehn elf und 16
liegen fünf jahre und schminke macht ein
15 jahre älter und in diesem fall sieht
sie hat extrem viel älter aus das heißt
aber nicht
du musst dich auf jeden fall schminken
wenn du meinen klub willst ich weiß
jetzt natürlich nicht wie alt du gerade
wirklich bist aber danke auch an dicht
schöne grüße und ja in deinem fall muss
man halt sagen make up machte ich
deutlich älter so machen wir weiter mit
ihr hier einmal ungeschminkt ganz normal
ganz typisch und ja denn jetzt haben wir
hier besteht ja das ist jetzt der erste
fall will ich sagen muss
sorry aber das hier wirklich nicht gut
aus ein spaß weise sie hat mir auch
einen text dazu gesteckt und zwar was
geht jetzt japan mache es nur spaß war
noch nie geschminkt in die
öffentlichkeit gegangen ps habe auf
beiden fotos keine filter oder sonstiges
benutzt du wär was ich mit winken blauen
grünen augenlidern wohlfühlt kann man
natürlich auch so rausgehen für mich
weil ich glaube das war jetzt damit
gemeint dass das als basis kein plan
ansonsten aber an dieser stelle schöne
grüße an natalia danke für die fotos und
die mir dass du dich vielleicht extra
für mich so schön geschminkt hass sowie
kommt zur nächsten personen workout dann
ja sie war gerade im fitnessstudio das
finde ich gut danke dass du mir das
mittags immer ganz wichtig sport machen
viel wasser trinken gesund ernähren und
ja das einmal ungeschminkt und das ist
geschminkt ist natürlich auch ein klarer
unterschied zu erkennen ich würde aber
die
im fall sagen sie sieht jetzt nicht
unbedingt älter aus in geschminkt
version als in ungeschminkt version was
man jetzt besser findet ist
wahrscheinlich jedem das seine der eine
findet es natürlich besser der andere
geschminkt mir ist es eigentlich egal
und deswegen auch schöne grüße an dich
dank für die fotos und wir machen weiter
mit der nächsten person die hatten wir
auch einen kleinen text dazu geschrieben
und zwar immer dass hier alex dieses
bildes für ein neues video format
geschminkt wurst so geschminkt ich winke
mich nicht weil ich gar keine lust habe
mich jeden tag 20 minuten mit meinem
make up zu beschäftigen ich mag den
videos und macht weiter so dabei handelt
es sich um dieses bild
und da muss jetzt erst mal sagen ich
würde jetzt mal so auf 12 13 14 schätzen
keine ahnung und ich finde es wirklich
gut ist dass du denkst und einfach sagt
hey ich brauche mir nicht schminken das
ist mir zu zeitaufwendig ich meine ganz
ehrlich man schmeckt man sich heute
schon in der fünften klasse oder ich
finde ich ein wirklich viel zu früh
deswegen leben nach diesem motto erst
mal weiter und irgendwann wenn er dann
mal den zwang hat sich zu schminken oder
so dann machst oder halt nicht dann lass
es ist ja jedem das einer durch wird
sagen zwei haben wir doch und zwar hier
einmal ebenfalls keinen namen ich habe
die bilder hatte schon vor ungefähr
einer woche die screenshot und manchmal
habe ich denen die namen noch im kopf in
diesem fall jetzt aber nicht falls du
das klassisch schöne grüße wir haben wir
einmal die ungeschminkt burschen werde
ich jetzt einmal 15 schützen und wenn
man dann einen weiter klickt kann das
halt auch schon älter rüberkommen also
auch auf jeden fall in starker
unterschied was ihr aber auch
aufgefallen ist sehr viele schicken das
ungeschminkt foto in wirklich absolut
grausam licht aufgenommen mit einem
taschenrechner und dann kommt das
geschenk foto in gutem licht auch noch
ein bisschen facebook darüber bisher im
filter drauf und ab geht's also am
besten sind natürlich fotos im gleichen
licht vielleicht auch direkt
hintereinander aufgenommen
das heißt wenn ihr darauf lust habt
schickt mir das gerne über instagram
daher sich alex wie gut aber hier kann
man auch auf jeden fall nur sagen
wirklich sehr hübsch und ok wir kommen
zum letzten fall fall schon kriminell
hier und zwar haben wir hier die person
obwohl die augen sind geschminkt werde
ich jetzt nämlich gesagt das ist
ungeschminkt da sieht sie älter aus als
geschminkt auf diesem bild
obwohl nehmen irgendwie sind hier so ein
bisschen die augen geschminkt und hier
die so ein bisschen make-up hof oder ist
schimmer hat keinen plan aber falls das
das geschminkte ist und das
ungeschminkte sein soll sie ist so
ungeschminkt älter aus als geschminkt
naja soviel dazu leute ich würde sagen
dass auf jeden fall noch oben da wenn
ihr noch ein paar haben wir nicht
vergessen ich schaue jetzt mal ob ich
morgen nach berlin komme oder nicht weil
mein flug ist halt weg und schickt mir
gerne über instagram euer foto einmal
geschminkt ein warum geschminkt ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen
haut rein und lang an alle die schon
foto geschickt haben